When the Bank of England raises interest
rates they're trying to fix inflation and
i think inflation will come down we'll
talk about that a bit more in a moment
they're trying to fix inflation but they're
doing nothing to fix the inequality which is
a fundamental problem i think this is a little
bit the problem with the way economists think
so the Bank of England is raising interestrates
a lot of people are worried about this what
it means. So i'm gonna do a quick explainer
on what's going on. So the Bank of England
is raising interest rates to deal with inflation i
think the most interesting point to realise here
is there's a real asymmetry between the causes of
the inflation and the attempt to fix the inflation
okay so i've talked about it a lot on this channel
so people will know, the government essentially
gave out £450 billion pounds of cash during Covid
which is a truly truly enormous amount of money
the way that worked at the time is the government
borrowed it from the Bank of England and then they
gave it out um and the Bank of England pays
interest on this money so as i've said a lot
it's very important to understand who got this
money okay, it's explained very clearly on the
very first video on this channel "why Covid-19 is
making the rich richer" that that money was largely
accumulated by richer people okay so during Covid
the government essentially printed and gave out an
enormous amount of money that ended up with
the rich and they pay interest on the rich
on the money to the rich so an enormous increase
in inequality um it was pretty much inevitable
that this would always cause inflation because
just simply because of the enormous size of it
it's important to understand that it alsocauses
a permanent cash flow from the government
to the rich because the rich have this £450 billion
now and the government pays interest on the
money it's actually the Bank of England that pays
the interest but the Bank of England is owned by
the government so financially it's coming from the
government okay um so during Covid the government
gave a huge amount of money out that has
been inevitably inflationary, if the government
wanted to deal with that inflation the sensible
thing to do which is exactly what i suggested
in the first video on this channel is i need to
take the money back which is basically taxation
um but that's not what they're doing what actually
is happening is that the central bank is raising
the interest rate and remember the interest
rate is the cash flow that the government pays
to the rich who have the money so if you
look at what's happening here in both
instances it's really bad for the government which
is the taxpayer and really good for the rich right
during Covid they gave the rich a ton of money and
now after Covid they're increasing the interest
rate that they paid to the rich on that money so
first the rich got a ton of money and now the rich
are going to get even more money every year from
the government so from an inequality perspective
and anyone who watches the channel regularly will
know, inequality is basically a cancer killing
our economy what's happening is is basically
terrible right huge amount of money was given
and now more money will be given every year and
that money will come from the government but also
from anyone who is in debt which is basically if
you have a mortgage if you have a large mortgage
as i explained in our video what is wealth
that mortgage is owned largely by richer
people you pay interest to the rich on your
mortgage and that interest will go up you'll
pay more interest to the rich so when the Bank
of England raises interest rates they're trying
to fix inflation and i think inflation will come
down we'll talk about that a bit more in a moment
they're trying to fix inflation but they're
doing nothing to fix the inequality which
is a fundamental problem and i think this is a
little bit the problem with the way economists
think they see the inflation but economists
have a massive blind spot for inequality
which nothing could be illustrating more than
the way nobody's speaking about it right now
and they're dealing with the inflation
but they're not dealing with inequality
so inflation will come down i'm very confident
inflation will renormalise it might take a year
or so inflation will come down but inequality will
not come down and what that means is inequality
will be left permanently higher which will mean
that ordinary people's standard of living will
be left permanently lower and rich people's
standard living will be left permanently higher
so inflation will come down but these
changes in relative price levels
mainly that energy prices and food prices and
things like rent have become permanent and also
house prices have become permanently significantly
higher relative to wages they will remain
so the central bank will succeed in its target of
reducing inflation but it will not succeed in re
re-normalising your living standards to what
they were before Covid, living standards will
be permanently worse now just like they were
realistically after 2008 for ordinary people
living standards will be permanently worse in this
country and and they will continue to deteriorate
so how do you stop that well the way you stop that
is to reverse the damage that you did during Covid
during Covid £450 billion pounds which is £10,000
pounds per adult was transferred from the
government to the rich explained in our first
video that's enormous it increases inequality
enormously um you need to fix that and the
way to fix that is by taking money back from
the rich which is taxation and that would be a
symmetrical way of solving the problem you give
money to the rich you want to fix it you take
money back from the rich what we did is we give
money to the rich and then we give the rich more
money to raising inflation right through raising
the interest rate right um so the central bank
will they'll fix the inflation but they won't fix
inequality and the way to fix inequality would
be to raise taxes but the central bank doesn't
control taxation right taxation is in the realm
of the government, the central bank only controls
monetary policy which is things like interest
rates the central bank can't tax the rich okay
so that should be when the government tax
the rich well is the government taxing the rich
i don't think i need really to comment on
that you know the chancellor-in-law's father
is one of the richest billionaires in the world
so the chancellor's father-in-law one of the
richest billionaires in the world doesn't seem to
be showing any inclination to taxing the rich those
things might be connected they might not not
for me to say um these guys are not seriously
talking about taxes in the rich which means they
probably won't get fixed so inflation will come
back down but living standards will continue to
decrease and decrease and decrease and decrease
um so then is the Bank of England at fault because
they don't control taxation policy well it's not
their fault that tax are not being raised but what
is their fault is there's a lot of very well paid
economists at the Bank of England whose job is to
protect the economy of this country okay we know
now that £450 billion pounds which is a truly
enormous sum of money went from the government
to the rich during Covid it should be obvious
that that's a big causative factor in what is
happening now. Who at the Bank of England of all
these well-paid economists is talking about it
Andrew Bailey gets paid half a million pound
a year he's the chief of the bank of England
is he talking about the massive increase
in cash holdings by the rich during Covid?
i haven't heard him talk about it in fact
all he said is that ordinary people should
not ask for pay rises well i think all the new
people should be getting pay rises right so
the Bank of England is not a fault in the sense
that they can't raise taxes but they are at fault
in the sense that here's a lot of very well
paid economists who should be protecting
the living standards of people in this country
who have allowed the largest ever and quickest
ever transfer of wealth from the government to
the rich and have simply said nothing about it
you know if your job is to protect ordinary people
and to manage inflation and there's an enormous
transfer of cash from the government to the
rich that causes inflation and damages ordinary
people's lives you should at the very least talk
about it and they're not talking about it so um
the Bank of England, look interest rates, the
market expects them to stay at about 2%
level and to stabilize there um not everto go
higher because they expect the economy to
stay weak, personally i think they will probably
come up and at some point come back down again
and i expect we will see something like a zero
interest rate probably within a couple of years
that's not what the market expects that's what i
expect um but that's because i think the economy
will be very very weak in the long run um but
the most important thing to understand is that
even though inflation will normalise living
standards will not normalise and that's a terrible
message but it's the truth um and the only way
to fix that is is to is to tax the rich because
when you increase inequality you improve living
standards of the rich and you decrease living
standards of the rest, that's what we're going to
see, um that will not fix itself and we canonly
fix that by fixing taxation policies, iwould really
love anyone who works at the Bank ofEngland
or who knows anyone who works the Bank of
Englandto get in touch with me and talk about
why they haven't said anything about this massive
transfer of cash and wealth to the richest because i
think that's, i would like to say it's criminal but to be
honest i think it's more a case of just stupidity
i've worked with a lot of economists and they're
not stupid people but they seem to be phenomenally
incurious people and i would love to know just
why nobody has spoken about it so if anyone in the
Bank of England can get in touch and say you know
maybe maybe someone has done it and if someone's
done it i'd love to see it but um that transferof
wealth has happened the Bank of England can't fix
it but they can talk about it and i really wish
they did because it's getting boring just being me
good?  we done? yeah